well that doesn't work
[ __ ] am i doing
hey am i stupid
holy [ __ ]
take your time i i am clearly
okay i don't think i can spawn
animals right
no i turned that off hmm
hello ballet hello hello we're all doing
well thank you
epic builder i know
shut the [ __ ] up it's so rude
it's okay
oh you had problem with your game too
oh [ __ ] let's do that
hey guys can you help me fix this i did
this wrong
just so it's symmetric
uh how do i do that again
what's the command for um
thank you meaner
yeah we should probably test this out
first um
okay can we can we uh have a raw chicken
in all the chests
but just put them a bit further away
like over here or something
can you guys help me with that
and wait where are six players so maybe
i had for
six chests for each one and just mimic
mimic what i did here for six as well
it will make sense i i promise
hey what is that thing called uh that
you have to shoot with an arrow
that explodes
it looks all 3d and cool
no not a target plot uh you make it with
obsidian
and crystal thank you
now it isn't how do i place it
no it's not okay let's do tnt then
talk does tnt blow up if you shoot him
with an arrow no he doesn't
we have to put in sodium first okay can
we set up five of them as well it needs
to have fire aspect
okay let's set up fire arrows
okay maybe space them out a bit so they
don't all explode
this is such a terrible idea but we're
committed now
they do everything for you well
okay we need to space them out more
teamwork work makes a dreamwork that's
right
yeah raw chicken in every chest yeah
even as partisan to work it is supposed
to be your work pewdiepie
hey we got some talented minecraft
builders here
all right
okay you can space them out a lot it's
fine
your own chores i'm trying to figure
this out
okay uh
and then let's put five more chat
how many are we now one two three four
five six seven
[Music]
um
i got a better idea
no bunk
this will be uh this will be epic trust
me
oops
okay all right
okay i love this okay what else can i
make them do i'm doing like an obstacle
course
so [ __ ] dumb
um
oh lava is good yeah
nothing complicated i just want it
simple
oh you guys are making it so nice well
done
you don't need a fence then it's fine
okay okay maybe we should just try it
out because i don't want to spend all
day on this [ __ ] [ __ ] oh a
cobblestone generator of course
that's the finale
what do you need to make a cobblestone
generator
okay okay we definitely have enough
stuff now
new drip leaf is fun yeah maybe we'll uh
we'll switch it up eventually but let's
start
let's start with this thanks for helping
me bill guys i appreciate it
okay okay and then the finale someone
said something about a name tag
oh the last one to name
name tag how do i turn off so i can
spawn
this is spawn animals or can i does it
mean i can spawn it
animals
man it's taking forever to connect
why are people joining now oh okay
because i
disconnected them sorry uh
hey where the [ __ ] are you going
ah
i don't know why i'm doing this
you ever start something and it was good
idea in your head and then
you just kind of have to keep it yeah
all right
yeah yeah i'll make an ammo i'll make it
out
okay
okay uh does anyone want to help me
build uh for an animal
oh god what do you mean look at what you
made that's awesome
can you make like a little bit of a jump
that you have like you have to run up
and then do a little bit of a tricky
jump to get to an anvil
can we do that that'd be sick over here
oh you need an experience potion what
are those called
will they get money for this yeah yeah
they're interns
let's just put a bunch of them in here
oh thank you whoever gave me that and
for being very
uh very kind and helpful appreciate it
oh you can just do that i didn't know
that
intern for pewdiepie incorporate
all right okay
you're building the course for me this
is amazing child labor no that's not
what
stop stop
what is that poor cheap doing okay i
think we're almost ready
the great water sheep all hail
okay okay that i think that i think
that's enough right
minecraft but i may call mine
they're unpaid in turn they have a
possibility of uh
okay okay okay what i finished this one
uh
silver and then uh
and then uh that's the finale
they need refreshments nah that they're
good
all right when you're done with this
i'll walk you through what it is you
gotta do it probably makes no [ __ ]
sense
we're out of gpu
you get paid in gpu i can arrange that
actually
okay okay okay okay we're good we're
good we're good we're good well done
guys
beautiful all right so once you're done
with that just come over here and i'll
walk you through it
uh so each contestants will start here
in your lane
pick a lane right now pick it wisely
you don't have to do it now actually
because i'm just showing that now i
think about it
okay um oh yeah i had something prepared
over here you have to wear the carved
pumpkin hat while doing this and you
have to use
first-person mode no cheating so in here
there's cardboard
if you want to make it more difficult
you have to wear the pumpkin hat
we kind of do this in sweden like a
course
i feel like uh oh yeah okay thank you
i'll do that
uh what you're going to do is going to
run over here
it's important you follow here okay you
run over here you grab the chicken
you run bang you cook the chicken
step 3 you have to eat the chicken it's
very important that you eat the chicken
after you eat the chicken you grab your
bow
and arrow and you shoot your respective
uh beacon but you have to do a 360 first
otherwise disqualification
all right everyone following so far
after 360 if you don't do 360
you have to redo that not
disqualification after that you have to
run over here
grab the tree i will be waiting for you
here
in order to continue you have to grow
a tree how i grow three fast felix well
if you say something to me that i'll
appreciate
i will give you bone meal which will
speed up the process
uh-huh it's up to you what to do on this
part
next step you run over here why is this
chest bug
and you have to make a cobblestone
generator
and i guess you have to prove that you
can do it
this is minecraft olympics yeah
um you get bonus points if you uh
if you do a good one next up you grab
your name tag
your bottom enchanting and then you have
to run all the way
all the way back all the way through
to the final obstacle course where you
will have to name
the llama
after you've done done the anvil the
last one to name the lava
is the ultimate championship
god i get that ego base sylvia shush
this is impossible too much stuff easy
to forget does anyone have any questions
then
the last one
did i say the last one i meant the first
one sorry
what did we get uh if we win
a secret it's a secret i will accept
bribes yes
uh bonus point for neat name
actually you know what if it's a bad
name i will uh i have to approve the
name
for you to win we're adding that
i have to i have to like the name if you
i don't like the name i'll pick the
second run rut
uh
thank you grace sorry by having a bad
day
and no copying other names sure yeah
okay
so everyone through their starting
positions people told me i should change
to survival
for this does everyone have survival now
if i do that
or is that for everyone
where do i have to do that no
how do i what was the game oh there we
go
there we go i want to be in creative
okay everyone to starting position which
is here
uh let's put a carpet so i i know where
you guys are i can't place a carpet on
that
there we go
oh sorry if you don't mind moving one
second
there we go i can't place it
all right
beautiful
look at you guys so helpful i appreciate
it what a great pair of
interns we need another lane uh
uh could you yeah
i will consider all of you for uh my
company okay soldier boy
it will have to you can do next round
okay
all right everyone ready i need a music
mega lavinia will
will do
okay all right all right all right all
right
does everyone remember should i run it
through one more time
oh how do i clear inventory
there we go no cheating smithing
oh everyone has to grab a pumpkin again
my bad
it's a lot of setup but we're almost
there nine year olds are so smart yeah
type in chat yeah okay so on my goal
i will count it down three two one go
okay
hey you got everything
yeah all right everyone ready all right
we're ready
three
two
[Music]
one no no no no no no no
no no no no
i said stop stop
stop stop stop you [ __ ] it up
it was three two one go not three two
one
go back errol go back through the start
point
no no no
no stop this get away with this stupid
chicken
come on come on god damn it i have to
reset this
yeah i don't care if you have a cooked
chicken all right
you
oh my god oh [ __ ]
there'll be no
okay i'll play music i'll play music how
about that all right
oh my gosh i can't even be mad because
you helped everything
ring a bell okay bella's good let's do
that cool
uh there's a cooked chicken here
you got me all the chickens there's
checking
no no no no no on the bell i'll set up a
bell
just making sure here you can't eat
why can't you you gotta eat the chicken
uh if you came in late you can join next
round
okay um
they can't eat the chicken how do i
solve that
okay set it to easy disability
i how do i [ __ ] do this
does that work
do you have a hunger bar now
it should work all right all right so
when i ding the bell
you go
you have to run for a quick moment for
it to work
is that [ __ ] slime coming here
oh for [ __ ] sake all right okay all
right the slime is uh
all right everyone to start in positions
here we go
there's no potion of hunger what are you
talking about
get the [ __ ] out of here slime we spent
too much time setting this [ __ ] up
for you to [ __ ] it up
[ __ ] it out why did i have to do a
[ __ ] chicken
okay here we go we're good slime's gone
okay here we go we better [ __ ] start
this before
all right
all right everyone ready
[Music]
great two
one go
good luck everyone get the chicken
everyone has their chicken oh they're
slimes [ __ ] them up you gotta cook your
chicken
oh but there's slimes three sixties you
gotta do three six eggs
[Music]
you gotta do three seconds all right we
have
four people qualified so far
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah they're going forward to the next
obstacle
which is to grow a tree the only way to
grow a tree
is to say something nice compliment give
me a compliment
you cute pee pee meaner you get a you
get
your flavor's got tear you get it
game plug what do you got
oh we got a tree
the knife flipping is very cool okay
all right we're just gonna drop a bunch
of this here
we got trees uh died okay okay
moving on to the next one you have to
build a cobblestone generator we already
got one
we got two cobblestone generators that
means we have two already
moving on half again
to the obstacle course meter poses on it
but he couldn't do it
he tries again
he's almost there he's at the end mill
right in the second we got kiddo going
super speed canoe so fast
waddle didn't have any lava no can't
meet her both died
bammy skittles that oh my god what a
turtle with that
here he goes but what did she name the
lava
[Music]
why would she name the lover oh will it
be good enough name for the llama
uh what is this what is this
every guy what's his name
no that's not good enough kiddo you have
to try again
he's looking cute that way there is me
nervous
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh the winner is me
it was looking cute hell yeah
oh man what a competition
what a race well done meaner pose kiddo
you get an honorable second place
that was well played well played
all right we should do this one more
time and i'll get rid of all the [ __ ]
slimes
oh god let's do
let's do it one more time
okay how do i turn up [ __ ] mobs
yeah yeah if you could get up okay
oh man that was hilarious
thank you kiddo
i made an obsidian generator
[Music]
okay you like the slime
maybe maybe the slime was good oh my god
maybe okay what what worked and what
didn't i think the trees thing was great
i'll definitely keep the night
um
we can set it up so uh we have some
lanes for the trees
that'd be good
so i know we know for sure
um we should put lava under the parkour
that's a good idea too
[ __ ] you slime
since some of you guys helped build it i
uh
we could also do teams but no maybe
that's too
make it one direction kind of like that
you had to run all the way but maybe
yeah
nice good solution
ah feelings hot that's also good
sorry llama you have to be sacrificed um
all right we got a new llama
looking good looking good what an
obstacle course let's put lava under
here
[Applause]
yeah this is good
i like this so we're improving it
do we have maybe the winner the winner
this time should switch out with the
soldier uh so i forgot the name soul
saul
boy
all right
you thinking of a better name this time
kiddo
i will watch that thank you meaner i
appreciate
appreciate that it's very kind all right
everyone gets a chance maybe we should
have more space for the cobblestone
generator
where the name tags the name tags were
supposed to be
here at the very end
boy okay we're lying yeah i'll switch
we'll switch out more people it'll be
funny
oh beautiful should we make
the obstacle course a lot longer as well
um
who's doing it
shovel for cobblestone silver bones you
did a great job with the
obstacle course would you mind extending
it
and kid i was helping too
at a boat ride [ __ ] hell
if we can make the uh it's pronounced
sausage boy
oh for [ __ ] sake
okay
we're doing it together it's not it's
not
unpaid if we do together it's like a
horse race yeah
i like this whoever's on the
should we add anything else we
definitely should add one thing every
time right
i don't know but with eyes block instead
okay
let's uh add more uh lava underneath as
well
oh mlg water bucket i like that that
should be the last jump of the obstacle
course
okay okay
if we can do that uh
rip people high ping
if
uh if so i can have a bit of build
ladders up to the top here on each one
of these
this is minecraft ninja warrior there
there you go perfect and on the top
there should be
uh
the anvil
and the maybe we should make them taller
yeah the anvil and the
i don't know
wait what's happening here oh you're
adding oh whoa
oh yeah that's perfect may i make them
connect here perfect perfect
perfect big brain
lava here
okay okay after we're done we're done
with this we're done
wait isn't that gonna burn up these hold
up let's be careful here
okay okay okay okay perfect perfect
perfect
you got to do the mlg water jump at the
bottom
there should be a chest then at the top
as well right
yeah with a water
water bucket i guess
you're already on to it so smart
this is awesome good job everyone
oh god it's on fire
maybe we should use iron fence at the
end here
beautiful oh sorry
sorry so sorry oh
[ __ ] sake oh my
start the single fireworks sure we can
do that
okay uh good job on the obstacle course
does it work
let me try it it works
can you make this a regular thing yeah
it's funny
uh again
is this the tree building uh the tree
growing
i need to prepare bone meal this time
should put a bed at the start does that
work
okay
are we still doing pumpkin heads um
yeah yeah we're still doing pumpkins
obviously the most important thing i
feel like it's a bit unfair whoever's
like on the bar over there maybe we
should do it i you know what let's keep
it for now
this looks awesome
no okay [ __ ] no pumpkin head then
creeper heads
okay are we are we uh are we ready
how's it going over here
well done all right let's run through it
uh
just in case uh people have been missing
okay here's the obstacle course
you start sleeping in the bed i will
start
by ringing a bell when you're not doing
the fireworks a bell sound once you hear
the bell
boom you head off you grab the chicken
you run back
you cook the chicken and you have to eat
the chicken as well
very important we will check the footage
afterwards no cheating
after the chicken is eaten you can shoot
grab a bow and arrow and you gotta shoot
uh
the end crystal but you gotta do 360
first
we will check the footage you got a 360.
oh that's good we should add that later
the pig race i like that
uh oh maybe we should we add a pig
to this part
no now let's not add more stuff for now
next time next round next round next
right next
yeah okay uh then
you gotta grow your tree everyone gets a
specific spot for the tree
uh i should mark that right where you
have to grow it
so i know whose tree is who
we can't what
oops
can we grow a tree like that
we will see with bone meal i'm sure you
can
trees won't grow that close let's try it
totally works will this grow
totally works i don't see a problem
oh god what have i done
[Applause]
that i i would argue the true part is
the
most important okay uh whoever's on the
last three rows don't have to do a 360
since your end crystals are further away
i think that's fair okay next
up you have to build a cobblestone
generator can we mark
as well so i know whose is who
[Music]
who did that to that chicken then you
grab your name tag
and they have to go all the way back
what's all this then uh all the way back
to do the obstacle course then
once you're done the obstacle course the
final part
is to name the llama it has to be good
name
and then you have to do an mlg 360 jump
down here
and then i guess you have to run all the
way back
through the course can't run on the
outside has to be through the course
and then last one to name the llama wins
but i have to approve the llama name
okay this works
let's do it everyone to starting
positions
this is it
okay so what do i have to do i have to
game modes
oops sorry spooky
here here here spooky uh
there you go
now
[Music]
yeah you can be in creative uh
what
oh kira you came late okay sorry i
didn't see you
nope there you go
okay creeper heads
uh let's put the bell here
bella is the girl sam you get a head
start this time
no second chance what is all this
okay
let's do this i'm starting the sound
once you hear the bell you're good to go
you have to be sleeping in your beds no
[Music]
i know head start
go
go whoa they got fireworks okay they
grabbed the chicken
we already have kiddo can't they're
gonna eat the chicken
oh kid i got the reader 6a i saw the
360.
oh spooky's through the 36th day oh we
got three things all the way right
the people on the right don't have to do
the 360.
okay you know surface
pack i described the uh
the thing but he has to give a nice
comment
you're very hot that's correct
[Music]
you're looking fine today pigs you're
right kiddo i am
uh spooky i'm the best spiller that's
right i am
[Music]
uh pits if i had a time machine i would
destroy that brit that's correct where
are you
i'm very cubic uh sure
yeah let's hear it fellas
huh kids you have pp exercise who said
that
who said that there you are
you know [ __ ] i'll just give it to it
sex come over me there you go
it's such a boy it's going people have
already built their cobblestone
generators
oh we got people at the obstacle course
what someone died no
surface peaches on it no it's everybody
had to restart
oh another night killer has to restart
somebody that's not the obstacle course
oh it's too difficult some say
oh kiddos going
i got more people joining the obstacle
course
soldier boy is at the very back
you can do it soulja boy we got kiddo
going for the jump
backhand kiddo do it
[Music]
here it comes will she have a good name
i have no xp well you should have
grabbed it
over there in the chest kiddo has to go
back
hit okay kale silver bones
we'll have to try his luck
poor kid okay will he he did it
unbelievable and he turned up city
sells our bunch
[Applause]
what is happening here i don't know
well silver bones have a good name
oh did the kiddo get xp or not
we will see
[Music]
you has to get xp simple bones what have
we got
llama zama not good enough
it gets no
[Music]
it's not good enough
you have to go back
here we go yes
oh no
oh no it's over once again
oh kid it's back this is their second
chance
oh but kingpunk is close
well the name of the llama be good
enough
[Music]
oh we got the jump no okay
didn't do it but cano did it
wait did someone what is happening here
we got axolotls
here we go we got waddle and kiddo very
close
and the song is out here we go this is
your chance kiddo pewds channel member
chat will decide
wait we need a verdict first it's a no
it's a no i'm sorry kiddo
[Music]
it's a no chad says no your turn kpog
[ __ ] i can't believe it
lingard language is not good enough
[Music]
either
sorry
the llama part is the hardest i'm sorry
no don't hit ling on dare you
we got waddle jenkins coming up no he
doesn't
some say the game is rigged some people
are false
is anyone close oh soldier boy has
finally made it
to the end could this this would be the
return of the century
there's no name tags left
you were supposed to grab the name tags
at the start soulja boy
did you forget to bring one they're over
there you have to redo everything
kendo is back for the third time we'll
kill to do it this time
[Music]
kid is coming up
here we go pizza sexy that's the good
that's good
the winner is kiddo
dude we have a second place
[Music]
the name tags are over here by the llama
they're in by the llama soulja boy
[Music]
surface fish are no name tags
[Applause]
you still here they're still getting
name tags here we go we got seven peach
hitting the llama disqualified
with food yeah uh chicken sure
[Music]
you get infinite g-fuel chicken flavored
wait what
spooky saya all right they get the game
the game the game's over
kiddo one well done
uh
you get a 20 dollar fortnite card
check your mail well played
oh well done well done
right now it was a rigged
oh man we should we should let more
people play
i'll do uh i'll invite another win
there we go we should definitely add a
pig and a stick this time around poor
lax ladles
maybe here you have to do the obstacle
course again but with a pig and a stick
that would make sense
so after you built the cobblestone
generator
wait we got some fake cobbles okay
who killed the chicken i don't know
we gotta reset this [ __ ]
i still have no idea how to build it
we should add the tree build maybe
later on because everyone seems to
actually we should definitely change
this because this is not fair at all
uh we should have them hit something
else
oh my screen mobile
um
okay let's reset the trees
i was done
a target block with redstone line what
does that mean
explain
okay let's uh make it nicer here as well
everyone has created right
okay okay good idea let's do that meter
pose
all right all right
if i leave and invite more people um all
right
i guess hmm trying to think how we get
more people in
okay so you guys can watch i like that
if you guys don't mind
i'll invite more people
okay so check out party link in the
description
i'll find you guys if you post under
minecraft and party and use the link
party
perhaps you find cool nice people to
play with like we're doing right now and
gotta get handed to you
pretty cool group
gives you matchmaking voice video in
chat for free
and that's what i'm using to play with
you guys today
hiccups okay
i'm inviting mez mezzock
taymor 46.
rosebud 750
selena b
or less
how many was that was that seven no
and raptorini
how many was that
sorry i love the fireworks
great touch
where do i want to pick race uh the pig
oh sorry the pig ray should be
right after the cobblestone generator so
you have to ride the pig
all the way back to the obstacle course
uh sure we can experiment with stuff
like that sure
that was eight no okay someone whoever
joins the last
will have to be sitting out
oh yeah
it's already hard to get up there yep
that's just how it goes
okay we got the pigs oh excellent i
guess we need to
chest maybe put in the cobblestone
generator
oh there that's smart mina
okay great
and then how do you how do you get to
the name tag
we're using big brain today well we
didn't get all the way through
i love how people forgot name tags
what came all the way didn't grab the
name
oh no anything can happen
why did i add fireworks
oh
oh so this will lit up
if you hit the button okay
cool
did none of the new people join
let's move the llama
best sexy llama around true
[Music]
sure
i'm just adding an element here of the
where the llama will be
hang it above llama no no no no
build the throne for it sure we can do
that
we can make this a bit bigger too
except for the llama okay great
okay yeah i got the llama here oh that's
a pig
oh you got it nice [ __ ]
sorry back on the throne baby there we
go
this is cool
you're gonna have some fence here for
effect
got an axle model lake for no reason
okay
i think we're almost ready
sure
looks great
okay why is our chest missing here
it's not supposed to be something in the
chest the arrow and the
is that here oh that's the tree part
um
okay well the axolotl is [ __ ] going
crazy
you missed the chest
okay
are you guys changing the obstacle
course or are you just resetting it
should have something here all right you
know i don't mind it
look at you guys okay
everyone grab your positions
did not everyone anything much more
people then
uh let's see how many people are we
okay tell me uh on some um
some names there's a limit
oh it reached the limit [ __ ]
let's just i feel like you guys should
run this through one more time because
uh and then we can switch out but
everyone
because i feel bad you guys worked on
and then you don't get to try it
player limit is 10 okay
kara you didn't do it last time don't
you want to do it
okay well next time you should
definitely do it then unless someone
wants to switch out
okay someone switched out that's nice of
you
thank you k-pong uh
no
yeah urine you're in kira
there you go
okay who's not competing
k-punk and kiddo okay that's fair
uh game modes oh [ __ ] what do i do
all right i'm setting survival on
everyone so don't
don't die
you're half a heart that's gonna be
tough silver
hey creeper helmet
here creeper helmet on
air cure surface creeper helmet
okay i'll just go through it one more
time
to make sure everyone knows it you start
on the band
you go this way you grab
the chicken [ __ ] chicken and then you
have to cook it
in the furnace after you cooked it
you gotta eat it
we're missing a bow in this
i'm adding bows
this is why it's good that we run
through it
there's arrows in my chicken chest wait
what
okay after that wait we have to set up a
line here i think
so people don't cross it um
let's do this
should there be there should be a bow
scenarios after the furnace yeah
a lava line nana we'll just do this
actually you know what lava line is cool
cannot cross you cannot shoot after the
lava line
oh my god silver please
you have to shoot oh that's tricky [ __ ]
the light has to lit up
for you to pass the lava after the light
lights up
then you may pass the lava after that
it's the tree growing competition
or you have to uh you can bribe me
for bone meal
so type whatever you want and i will
consider giving bone meal
the fence will burn [ __ ] the fence is
burning guys
chat just informed me and they are
correct
okay there we go fix that little problem
there we go no problem here
at all
[Music]
it's perfect
or you can just do that
i don't think that works
it's fine that's fine okay after the
tree has grown
um you have to make cobblestone
generator
after you've made cobblestone generator
you have to take your pig and go all the
way
all the way back
somehow through the lava
you have to sacrifice your pig in the
lob actually
and don't forget your name tag yes your
name tags are here don't oh nice well
done
i go all the way
do the obstacle course all the way
name your llama do an mlg jump
all the way down
should we add nah
nah i think this is enough already then
you have to run all the way back
stop swimming in lava and name the llama
but i
i have to prove the normal name okay
here we go we're ready everyone to the
starting point
stop swimming everything
everything good
kira is trying to look at comfort zone
generator um
well well well how the turntables you
can just copy other people's design
okay silver buns back to starting
position
grab your creeper hat
soldier so boy cripper hat
all right here we go are we missing
anyone
no we're not clear inventory thank you
[Music]
uh
i need grass for the tree
really
just to be safe
let's that remove your creeper head for
[ __ ] sake all right fine
okay on the bed on the bed everyone
here we go we're starting
let me just start the music
we go the race of the century it's about
to begin
starting position starting position
don't leave the bed can't leave the bed
we need the ascor theme
sake
which one is that
[Music]
okay
oh everyone's on the bed oh god the
fence is on fire hold up
okay we're good my hunger is full
you have to run a bit then three
two one
go their contestants are up
they grab their chicken characters
inside the first he's cooking his
chicken
[Music]
the chicken is being cooked memer posted
you eat the chicken
did you eat the chicken oh we got one
light lit up
we got two lights set up
[Music]
surface peach is on and cactus oh
this is tricky one
you have to grow a tree now poojs
or confine i don't know what that means
your music's gone tear there you go sure
[Music]
surface is on cactus sure fine whatever
you get bone meal if you give a
compliment
it's that simple you look handsome who
said that
there you go
uh akira you asked politely
[Music]
and yeah yeah there you go
i'm just gonna leave the rest of the
phone wheel for the rest of the
contestants
oh and they're on with it we're there
it's too fast i can't giggle cactus has
this pig
now we have to sacrifice the pig
you have to sacrifice the big cactus you
have to sacrifice the pig in the lava
cactus you're gonna get disqualified
cactus that's the second we're there he
goes cactus has sacrificed the pig
surface peach is ready to sacrifice pig
the pig has to die surface the pig has
to die surplus
you're failing you will get disqualified
if the pig don't die
[Music]
there we go all right you can sacrifice
the pig at the lava at the obstacle
[Music]
course
wait has only what is going on
we got waddlej going up oh i tried
swimming lava
is anyone at the tower yet who's in
[Music]
first
surface beach coming up it's got his
name tag
no fail at the second last jump
oh what a tragedy the obstacle course
is so difficult the last voice
ate the lava
here we go
oh we got three at the same time we've
never been this close before
no but cactus and minor just everyone
died
[Music]
how do you do this is so difficult
everyone is dead
oh they have to run back all the way of
course
to get their xp and name tags
[Music]
here they come characters coming in
strong taking the lead
oh so fast whoa rocket speed
soldier hate them ate the lava again
they don't swim in lava silver bones
right after
nope failed again this is too difficult
apparently
everyone's dying
all right i'm changing the rules mid
game rule
keep inventory
[Music]
it's true to make it a little more
simple
oh will surface peach make it oh cactus
is on the top
he nailed zeke
[Music]
but can cactus through
the mlg jump it remains to be seen
[Music]
here he goes no it's a fail
i guess it doesn't matter now that i put
keep inventory on
now you have to do it you have to do the
jump doesn't matter
[Music]
cypress peaches on it
can i do whatever you do no he hanging
[Music]
so far it's anyone's game
meaner pose coming back
no he didn't need that in la la waddle
what is he doing
oh so close
wait check llama did someone do it
i didn't see you do the the jump you
have to do the jump
[Music]
cactus did you do the la the mlg jab
i didn't see it you have to do it
this is the longest one so far
silver bones coming in for the second
time
[Music]
there's cheating going on there's water
on the llama
[Music]
unbelievable
oh so close
oh i came right again on the lava
[Music]
can mean opposed to it he's named his
name tag
but can he do the jump meter do the jump
incredible he just has to blame the lava
[Music]
but we also have cactus coming up can he
do the jump oh he did it
this is going to be a close one
meaner's coming up to llama
[Music]
what is the name pierce and right there
our cute couple i'm afraid that's not a
name that's a sentence meaner
that is not good enough you have to go
back
although i do agree nice try
cactus coming up floor gang for life
chad will decide chad will decide
chad says no i'm sorry cactus you have
to do it again
[Music]
what there's too much to keep track
it has to be a good name
[Music]
too basic they said
silver coming up second try
[Music]
can he simply do the jump no failed in
the last second
[Music]
oh beaner's pose is back just has to do
the jump
[Music]
no
has anyone given up yet cactus coming
back
[Music]
can connect to the mlg jump
oh okay let's go down people what's the
name nobody get enough
just has to do the final stretch
[Music]
this is safe it all comes down to this
what is the name peter's looking fresh
that's not a name
that's a sentence
it's so good
wow this is difficult
dudes this is rigged no it is sad
[Music]
surfer speech comes pewdiepie the llama
gun
i don't want to be a llama that's not
gonna be there
can someone name this llama please
[Music]
chances no i'm sorry i'm sorry
i don't eat the lava
will someone be able to name this llama
all right we got some um some stuff
changing here
[Music]
silver bones again cactus is here okay
okay
how does part they mean the llama okay
[Music]
chat we'll have to decide chat
it's a yes cactus wins
poopy pi1 apparently
dude yes
you deserve the throne
[Music]
well played
silver bones close second you did good
mean oppose you as well
[Music]
surfer as well i mean well
i don't know what you did waddle but you
did great
same for your camera well done
[Music]
oh you can see the game sorry
what
crazy time thank you guys all for
playing
[Music]
kept dying on the ladder yeah
i'd say we're all winners except
the llama for having the name popiah
thank you everyone who believed in me
unless we got her thanks for helping
build it thanks for everyone for
watching that's hilarious
the first yearly pewdiepie olympics
well done guys super fun i use
party to connect with everyone today
it helps you find nice people to play
with it's a great service
you get matchmaking voice video and text
chat for free
you unlock achievements as you host and
join parties and receive positive
feedback
and it supports almost any game title so
check out
it's circling all right bonus points to
service
amazing amazing
so good the olympics i like that
amy that's great
thanks for joining everyone well
played yeah let's do this again it was
super fun
we'll save we'll save this uh obstacle
course and we'll uh
we'll keep adding and changing it
all right thanks guys
bye bye bye bye say bye bye
picture together yeah let's do it
[Music]
bye chat thanks for joining
bye bye
absolute madness